[Música]
hola
para comer
estas ideas innovadoras que vinieron
para que estando en alcalá de henares en
españa la sociedad española
[Risas]
[Música]
para evitar que es una alternativa que
sirvió para que los implicados de una
universidad de la habana dijera mi
indignación para que yo pudiera dar
también una conferencia en la
universidad de la mano y estando en la
universidad de la habana después de
escuchar mi conferencia es que se me
acercaron en la noche los directivos de
esta universidad para hacerme la
propuesta de que si yo el tema era tan
importante era tan novedoso banano se
cultiva en muchas partes del mundo y
todas las partes donde se cultiva banano
controlan con químicos la sigatoka negra
que es la principal enfermedad del
banano
y eso fue la idea que realmente cambió
el pensamiento de la habana y
propusieron de manera tan importante y
nos dieron los
[Aplausos]
apoyo europa y las universidades
y otras verduras y luego
ya con todos esos elementos que se
propuso la candidatura fue aceptada y
luego participamos con toda la historia
ya en estocolmo donde les comentaba que
fue importante y realmente codearse con
investigadores con científicos de todas
partes del mundo y estar participando en
un concurso de un premio nobel lo cual
pues era el primer ecuatoriano que tenía
la oportunidad de participar en un
premio nobel
luego bien
para lo cual diseñamos tratamientos de
prendes de la mano de la figuración como
el de las personas con una frecuencia de
explicaciones de 4 y 8 días luego
teníamos el aspersor mínimo luego que
las personas extremos y el convencional
luego el material que se utilizó para
[Risas]
esto dio como resultado en primer lugar
plantas muy vigorosas plantas donde no
tenían una sola pizca de lo que es la
sigatoka negra durante todos los cuatro
años que duró y que hemos venido
trabajando en estos diez años ustedes
pueden observar la plantación de banano
completamente limpia completamente lo
sana
luego el fuste también el diámetro del
fuste era muy vigoroso estos equipos son
los equipos que producimos nosotros hay
una facultad técnica de la universidad
católica nosotros mismos
los animadores
y luego vemos ya la respuesta del uso
del ozono con esta tecnología donde se
puede observar el racismo muy dudoso con
muy buenas características agronómicas y
la infección
como podemos encontrarlas
no se logró determinar a través del
tratamiento
y concibe los tratamientos avanzados
[Música]
nosotros le damos a todos los vendedores
de mí
congresos de bananas
y
i
[Risas]
tuve la función de decirles nuevas
gracias
el nuevo nobel
por su intención
y entonces le demostramos con esta área
posibilidad es efectivamente el la
presencia del oso nos dura hasta 30
minutos estacionados en el agua
luego los tipos de personas que usábamos
que eran super foliar siempre tanto el
small drive como el xxi howell el peso
de los racimos también era muy
importante y aquí vamos a hablar un
poquito más sobre esta es importante
mencionar que el ozono no solo es capaz
de oxidar la miseria de los hongos y
romper las paredes para evitar que
produzcan esporas y diseminar la especie
ese es el efecto que tiene el ozono en
el control de los hombros de los virus y
de las bacterias sino que además de ello
tienen la capacidad de oxidar los
elementos que están en estado insolubles
amarrados a las vísceras coloidales del
suelo tanto a la arcilla como la materia
orgánica los libera y se los pone
disponible a la planta eso es lo que
expresa esta diapositiva donde vemos que
en el tratamiento 4 con el excel powell
es donde se encuentra la
el tratamiento que está con un color
morado con color morado es el
tratamiento que se puede observar donde
hay la mejor dispositivo y luego vemos
que el sistema óptimo de éstos es
justamente el tratamiento 4 donde se
encontró
los mejores resultados tanto en el
control y manejo de la ciudad toka negra
como también un mayor peso en racismo un
mayor número de kloster mayor número de
mano mayor número de hojas y un mayor
número de fuste
quería también comentarles algo de los
anexos porque nosotros seguimos
investigando nosotros nos paramos a
investigar a pesar de que los
presupuestos que se dan para
investigación en nuestra universidad es
ínfimo sin embargo siempre hemos tenido
apoyo de nuestra universidad y también
apoyo de se necesita y hemos seguido
investigando y encontramos que si bien
es cierto que lo son no se encapsula en
el agua por 40 minutos
logramos encontrar que mezclado con un
aceite vegetal en los otros es capaz de
durar hasta 30 días encapsulado en los
dobles enlaces del aceite eso es lo que
ha servido para que nosotros ya
desarrollamos una nueva metodología
desarrollamos a un proceso a través del
cual lo hemos utilizado ya para
controlar la virosis de la papaya hemos
usado ya este es el equipo que me
acompaña siempre el doctor lenin fácil y
dinero cristóbal aguirre y miren la
forma de cómo se aplica a nivel de
laboratorio porque nosotros siempre los
trabajos primero lo hacemos a nivel del
laboratorio aislamos el hongo de la
sigatoka de la manilla de la virosis o
doctora lo aislamos y lo ponemos a
crecer en un medio cultivo y luego le
aplicamos el ozono del aceite como son y
vemos como en los tratamientos donde se
aplica el aceite como sólo se logra
detener el crecimiento y donde no se
aplique el aceite como son o el hongo
sigue creciendo eso no demuestra que
efectivamente el aceite
no está cumpliendo con su cometido
también aquí hay otra experiencia de
prolongar la vida verde del banano es
otra de las
las ventajas que tiene el uso de esta
metodología el hecho solo de sumergir el
cluster de banano en un agua como solo
es capaz de incrementar 21 días
la vida verde del banano aquí podemos
ver en esta diapositiva cuando no tiene
0 partes por millón el hongo sigue
creciendo pero en la medida positiva del
lado que tiene dos partes por millón ha
detenido su crecimiento
aquí lo que estamos trabajando ahora con
sus años de palma el pce es una
enfermedad que está diezmando ya 120.000
hectáreas en la provincia esmeralda no
estamos ya con ellos haciendo un trabajo
con resultados preliminares
muy buenos aquí también para el hongo de
la manilla entiendo que aquí también la
zona de quevedo es una zona donde se
cultiva mucho cacao y el cacao pues
disminuye hasta en 40 y 50 por ciento de
los rendimientos
a pesar de usar químicos siguen
afectando la manilla sin embargo
nosotros vemos aquí en esta diapositiva
que cuando se utiliza ozono a tres
partes por millón o cinco partes por
millón se detiene el crecimiento y
cuando no se utiliza ozono el hongo
sigue creciendo otra demostración más de
que la efectividad que tiene el ozono y
aquí el trabajo que hacíamos en palma lo
estábamos aplicando al estípite de la
palma y le hacíamos un orificio con un
taladro y luego le inyectamos 50
centímetros cúbicos es va para allá
también para la virosis de la papaya
hemos encontrado que da un control
efectivo de la virosis
bueno la aplicación del aceite ozono con
dron también es otra forma de aplicar lo
que también ya manejamos estamos
haciendo aplicaciones en bananeras con
drone y ya con avionetas también esto
también es importante miren tenemos un
cliente de la zona del carchi un tío
dice el tío de carpas de la atleta
sterling que ganó la competencia en
italia y el cultiva papas en el carchi y
claro nosotros no podemos ir a la cárcel
porque está muy lejos pero nos llamó por
teléfono y nos pidió que le enviaremos
por transporte cinco litros de aceite
socializado se lo enviamos por
transporte y la respuesta que ha tenido
para el control de rhizoctonia que es la
principal enfermedad en la papa ha sido
excelente
también para el arroz para controlar la
pyricularia y para controlar el
vaciamiento del grano es excelente
y esto es realmente lo último que
estamos trabajando en el agosto 9 fue el
último ensayo que hicimos
con la famosa enfermedad que se nos
avecina el mal de panamá raza 4 claro no
podemos trabajar con el mal de panamá
raza 4 porque no lo tenemos aquí pero ya
lo tienen nuestro vecino colombia ya lo
tiene ya lo certificaron que hay
alrededor ya de 200 hectáreas afectadas
y que por las últimas informaciones
llegaron a 1500 hectáreas afectadas ya
con este mal de panamá
es posible que por más control que se
haga por más
agrocalidad ministerio agricultura que
ponga a estos pediluvios rodiluvios y
todas las medidas de control que se
tomen las esporas de este hongo que vive
en el suelo van a llegar a nuestras
plantaciones de banano y tenemos que
estar preparados de alguna manera esta
es una forma de
que estamos trabajando ya nosotras a
nivel de laboratorio y hemos encontrado
resultados positivos ustedes ven la
diapositiva donde se hizo la aplicación
de ozono hacia el lado izquierdo
y ver su la diapositiva donde no se
aplicó ningún tratamiento de ozono el
crecimiento es exponencial
a diferencia de acá que el crecimiento
se ha detenido
y acá otro trabajo también
el uso del aceite ozonizado ustedes ven
en el testigo donde se observa
que sigue creciendo que es la última las
últimas cajas petric y a diferencia de
la
cinco tratamientos o cuatro tratamientos
anteriores donde se utiliza aceite
socializado el crecimiento se comparan
este crecimiento con este crecimiento
del testigo van a darse cuenta que
efectivamente están logrando los
objetivos planteados
bueno si realmente esta metodología de
usar ozono para evitar el uso de
químicos en la agricultura es muy
importante que ustedes la conozcan y por
eso yo felicito realmente a los
organizadores de estos eventos porque es
la única forma donde se puede hacer
conocer estas ideas innovadoras estas
ideas que van a servir para todos
nuestros a personas que están vinculadas
de alguna u otra manera con la actividad
agropecuaria y decirle que el planeta
tierra ya no aguanta más los niveles de
contaminación que si bien es cierto que
cuando una abeja llega a una planta
contaminada con pesticidas las horas de
ellas están contadas pero no solo las
obras de las abejas las horas de todos
nosotros que habitamos este planeta
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]